I i graduated from the university of
detroit in aeronautical engineering and
went right to Boeing I had been through
air force rotc but never really did
receive a commission i went to boeing to
work as a civilian engineer primarily a
lot was on military aircraft in those
days were b-52s inkay c-130s and c-130
transports and the first airplane that I
flew at Boeing was a not as a pilot as
an engineer the Boeing the prototype of
the Boeing 707 which was called the 367
dash 80 and at that time we were putting
a pratt & whitney engine on the side of
it which was known as the jt8d and was
going to be the engine for the 727 which
at that time was on the drawing board
and so we did flight test to see how
that would work strapped on the side of
a 707 and that was the first job I had I
actually went to Boeing great fear that
I was assigned to a drawing board in to
do analytical work and to solve
equations and I wanted to be in the air
and so very fortunate I was able
fortunately I was able to connect with
the chief of flight test and I moved
into flight test very early and I spent
that short career at Boeing as a flight
test engineer and got to do a lot of
flying and a lot of piloting also so it
was great experience for me I liked like
the aircraft industry because they had
great toys and they great great
equipment and they had the best
equipment in the world and in those days
I didn't like the idea of having to work
for a corporation my father had never
worked for anybody but himself not to
successfully but always for himself and
when I realized that I couldn't really
accomplish what I wanted to accomplish
within the confines of a corporation I
look for another place to go and went to
law school at nights
however in between I did go to graduate
school in engineering at Wichita State
Boeing sent me there and suggested I go
there and I did and then later on I
finished law school at night
well a couple of things that early on I
thought Barry Goldwater was running for
president in those days and he was a
conservative I didn't understand the
difference between the Democratic Party
in the Republican Party but i liked
Barry Goldwater and he said if you want
politician you're you're going to have
to get a law degree I said I could never
get into law school and I was told that
you can get into law school you just
have to talk to the right people so I
went to law school and ask them if they
whether they ever had an aeronautical
engineering applied for law school and
they said no and I said I'm going to
give you a chance to try so and I found
that in a short order i was in courtroom
designing things aircraft things
primarily with felt tip pens on easel
boards in front of juries and when I was
getting large verdicts against the
industry all of a sudden they were
listening to me and making changes that
I was never able to make as a young
engineer when I was in the industry so
I never really looked at it from the
standpoint of money it was very
difficult for me to get a million
dollars out of my mouth because I had
never seen it in the context of the real
world I had to learn to stand in front
of a jury and say in conclusion I want
you to send a message back to the
aviation industry and I want you to find
a verdict for my client in the amount of
and then I'd have to kind of choked hard
and two million dollars and then after I
got my first two million dollar verdict
I was in the elevator and the operator
of the elevator was had been the jury
foreman on the case that I had just
tried and I asked him I said well why
did you give my client two million
dollars he said that's all you asked for
so I thought well maybe next time I'll
ask for a bigger number I one time ask
shortly thereafter ask for 10 million
dollars and the defense lawyer I got up
and stuttered and he said he just asked
for 10 million dollars you know I
couldn't paid him to say I couldn't to
say that again I want to get that number
up there twice and so he gave it to me
again and they punished me and only gave
me three so I I found that that system
in those days worked well to get the
messages to the industry and we changed
need a lot of changes that saved a lot
of lives
I think it's gradual in you know if we
went back Oh 15 years ago you would say
that the Democratic Party the liberal
side of the country was very much in
favor of people's access to the
courthouse I don't see that at all
anymore I think with the latest
administration there's there had their
tort reform people the same you know the
same party that we looked at as being
the People's Party our will support tort
reform today
well I think there's a big difference
between those concepts a great attorney
and what makes somebody effective in the
courtroom very few lawyers actually
tried cases and especially jury cases in
big law firms the what we call the Silk
Stocking law firms they call the people
to go to court litigators trial lawyers
of the type that was my own personal
experience is a small breed of people
and they usually aren't the lawyers from
the fancy law schools from the Ivy
League law schools and what have you
those we call the litigators the the
real trial lawyers that did the kind of
thing that I'm talking about the kind of
thing that Ralph Nader supported
substantially to a large extent are the
street fighters they're the people that
went into the night law schools they're
the people who know how to talk to
people and who live in a people's world
is compared to a corporate world one
could argue what's a great lawyer but
from my perspective doing what I was
trying to accomplish it was the latter
it's the more Street fede at moores
street fighting people's type of lawyer
and not the smooth extremely academic
well-educated not that we shouldn't all
be well educated but the kind of lawyers
that can really communicate with people
and that's a small group of people if I
try a lawsuit in the United States
against the aircraft industry today I
could tell you probably within 12
lawyers who's going to be on the other
side no matter what state I'm in
well i would say were would be where I
would go Clarence Daryl I read
everything Clarence Darrow of everything
Clarence Gerald ever tried what was
great about him was he could speak to
people in people's language he used to
say he used one cylinder words he could
speak in a very people's way it's very
difficult for many lawyers to get kind
of down in the jury box and get grass
roots and be able to really communicate
with people on a level that can be
understood especially we're talking
about mathematics chemistry physics
aerodynamics that's very difficult so it
takes a being kind of a high school
physics teacher a mr. wizard mr. science
sort of approach and that's what I
always tried to do myself
of all the systems i have seen around
the world and i have been in many legal
systems in addition to the United States
I think it's the best I have seen there
is some argument for instead of having
lawyers or judges be lawyers that either
came from the political arena or from
the practicing law arena to have judges
actually educated as judges I know in
Korea they do that you go to judge
school or you go to law school and
there's a difference between being a
judge and a lawyer as far as in our
system trying a case in front of a judge
as a finder of fact is compared to in
front of a jury as a finder of fact i'll
take the jury anytime over the judge the
judges have their prejudice prejudices
as anyone does as the jury does but at
least with the jury you have six or
twelve people to spread those prejudices
along you don't know when you're talking
to a judge you know what he's thinking
what his prejudices are what he likes
what he doesn't like who he was mad at
that morning or who he planning on being
at mad at the next day it's it's a very
scary system when you only have one
finder of fact you and you can't ask the
JED well what's your religion you know
what do you believe in what do you hate
what do you dislike in a way you can
find those things out from juries and
you can make us at least a selection
process and again you get to spread it
out over a group of people instead of
one person so the jury system I think
works much better for settling disputes
and for understanding what the facts
really were in a way that they're kind
of understood by a good cross-section of
the peers of the people who are in the
trial where as they say just a judge
trial is not you have to live with the
prejudice to go with that one particular
individual there could be a case made
for more of a blue ribbon jury in the
case of technical cases but that has a
lot of problems all
so I've read about it a bit I think the
system we have for civil cases which is
rare because not very many countries
actually use juries and civil suits kind
of conflicts between people or between
people and corporations I think it's
probably the best system i have seen and
even though the jury's may not be very
sophisticated in mathematics chemistry
physics or medicine they understand the
impressions and that's important
well you have to really look at the
dynamics of the particular courtroom you
have to think of where did how did the
judge get on the bench if you're in
federal court the judge was appointed by
the basically the executive branch the
president that was in office at the time
and he was appointed and that is what's
called an article three judge it's based
on the united states constitution
article 3 article three judges have
their job for life so that extent it
makes them a bit more objective because
they know that if they say something or
make a ruling that is unpopular they
don't lose their job they've got that
job for life that's a good thing and a
bad thing the bad part of it is it's
it's becomes kind of a power trip and
they realize that they've got that power
for life and a lot of times federal
courts are not very sensitive to
people's needs and people's conflicts
they believe that they were ordained
when they got their robes some how to
deal with more sophisticated issues like
corporations and patents and in federal
issues and it's sometimes hard to get a
federal judge to really be sensitive to
people's issues now on the other hand in
the state court systems the judges are
either appointed or elected and they
have a political connection somehow and
you have to look and see what that is it
may be that yeah when in the federal
system as I said the the judges are
appointed by the sitting president the
executive branch the United States
government and they have that job for
life and if they it's very difficult to
ever be removed as a federal judge you
can say something and do some of the
worst things against people against
corporations or offensive things and you
still are there for life so that gives
them a little level of arrogance which
is difficult I often say about federal
judges that they think they were
ordained when they got their robes not
to say there isn't some very good in
very
federal judges but to a large extent
federal courts see themselves as very
sophisticated they really don't see
themselves as courts for people they see
themselves as courts for corporations
and patents and federal trade issues and
what they would consider the more
high-powered and sophisticated things so
in the federal system you have to
realize that and oftentimes it's
necessary to play to the jury which is a
jury of people and it's it's difficult
you have to assess the whole situation
because no matter how much the jury may
be on your side a federal judge has a
lot of power to totally destroy your
case our federal judge can say things
out of the side of his mouth to the jury
that makes you look like you're
violating justice it looks like you're
you're being a bad person these are
trying to go in a wrong direction so you
have to be able to manage that that's a
whole different thing when I try cases
against United States government which I
have many times you do not have a jury
it's always better to have another
co-defendant in the case where you have
a right to a jury at least against one
party for example against the United
States for air traffic control for
example and at the same time against
some corporation or airline so you have
a jury at least in the courtroom and
then the judges under the pressure of
having to pay attention to the jury and
not look like he's offending the jury
and not be totally inconsistent with the
jury so a jury is a great safety valve
in that context so I always tried to do
that if I can if you don't have a jury
in a federal system you're going to have
to play to the prejudices of the court
and the judge and so you have to learn
those quickly and there's a few tests
that i use for an example to find out
where i think that judge may go if i
reach a little fire on behalf of my
client or you know push some particular
issue so it's more much more sensitive
in the state court system judges are
elected and are elected by the community
or by the
shins that are in that community and so
they're much more sensitive to being
offensive and they're much more likely
to be people's courts so that's usually
my preference I was I walked in front of
a Baldy district litigation panel
recently where they were trying to
remove my case to federal court and the
senior judge on the panel has said when
I walked up to the podium and here comes
shadon again with his never-ending quest
to stay out of federal court so now I
have developed their reputation
I never have used a jury selection
system I've never used jury consultants
I've read novels about them I've seen
them in movies I have always just kind
of gone with it from I guess i would say
a seat-of-the-pants approach I find that
most of the cases I try hour-long cases
they aren't things that went would go on
for one or two days they typically would
go on for two weeks to two months I try
to wear well with the jury learn never
to overreach to confront everything to
avoid nothing and to be really straight
and honest about it never overreach
after a couple of days the best and
worse to people understand that and you
know they tend to listen and they do the
right thing I mean you might find a very
difficult person on a jury but the rest
of the jury can brings them around
well one very interesting way to look at
what happened in a plane crash why they
are plane crashed is to follow the
history of the National Transportation
Safety Board who has been that that
board governmental body has been
assigned the responsibility to
investigate along the plane crashes all
types of transportation crashes I
understand it from the perspective of
plane crashes because I've worked on it
for many years the National
Transportation Safety Board
investigative team usually ends up being
a team made up of the airplane
manufacturer the engine manufacturer the
avionics manufacturer and sometimes the
operators in the case of an airline's
the airlines are fairly involved there
is never anybody on that team that
represents the passengers the people or
the pilots other than in the context of
the pilots for the airlines and being
employees of the airlines so doing the
extent they're looking at the accent
investigation as being is preparing to
defend themselves should a claim be made
against them so the investigation is
kind of like the Fox watching the
chickens it's you know right from the
beginning it's been in the direction to
take the blame or the cause off of the
manufacture of the engine the airplane
the avionics or in the case maybe of the
air traffic controllers in that sense
the FAA is always part of the
investigative team the Federal Aviation
Administration so often you'll read a
National Transportation Safety Board
report as to the cause of an accident
and when you investigate the facts and
that's what we do from a technical
standpoint we do our a lot of our own
technical work and exit investigation
where we find that it's night and day I
mean which you reading the NTSB report
and what really happened happened are so
different and he's an ad that usually
airplane crashes are a cause of a
combination of things there are many
things that go into why the airplane
crashed and it may
be the crew in part it may be what I
call design induced pilot air in other
words the design was such that it begged
for the pilot to make a mistake and and
that's not a good design sometimes it's
a combination of the crew acting in an
incorrect way under much pressure to a
simple malfunction a broken bowl to
loose part a leaky fuel system or
something of that nature more often than
not it's a combination of things it
isn't any one thing unfortunately in the
system the cause of a crash is not
usually dealing with really why the
airplane crashed it is dealing with what
are the economic interest for an example
the insurance industry they're only a
handful of insurance carriers who
represent the big players like the major
air carriers the Boeing Airplane Company
those kind of people are those kind of
entities so for example if let's assume
we have the a large insurance company
who carries their insurance for the air
carrier like American Airlines or United
Airlines and they also carry the
insurance for the manufacturer of the
airplane like Boeing they have to look
at what their risk is from the day they
are plane crashed there may be three
hundred people were killed or 150 people
were killed a lot of issues they may
have sold off a large portion of their
risk for an air carrier let's say ninety
percent to some foreign insurance market
like Lloyd's or some French market or
combination thereof and they may have
held on to only ten percent of the risk
but in the case of the manufacturer they
may have held on to fifty percent of the
risks in sold off fifty percent so they
know from day one at the time the plane
crashes where their biggest risk is
they're better off having it being an
air carrier problem than being an
airplane problem because they've sold
off most of the
risk for the carrier and they're only
holding a small percentage of it so
there's a motivation right from the
beginning to make sure that the people
who are in the investigative team are
those people are going to protect their
financial interest the FAA mail be
looking at themselves as the target from
the standpoint of air traffic control or
certification of an aircraft or
something of that nature they've got
that into interest to protect so it's a
very complex process in general aviation
small aircraft which we do a lot of and
have done a lot over over the years it's
it's fairly simple because we have a
main engine manufacturer and airplane
manufacturer and we have somebody from
the NTSB who is much less schooled in
the Aeronautics in the power plant than
the manufacturers who are on the team
helping them so the result is usually
driven by the manufacturer of the
airplane or the manufacturer of the
engine when you get to air carriers it
gets a little bit more complicated in
the NTSB gets much more involved from a
technical point of view they have a good
metallurgical lab for example and their
metallurgical people will look at
metallurgical parts but again the result
is substantially driven by the
manufacturer of the airplane in the air
carrier
I don't think that the NTSB does the
correct job in protecting the passenger
there are so many issues for an example
if you take a Boeing Airplane like the
model 737 that's kind of the workhorse
of the world industry I mean they only
have one competition and that's Airbus
and for the NTSB to come out and say
that's a defective airplane is almost
impossible thing because it destroys the
balance of trade for example there are
huge issues at stake so they come up
with some mealy-mouth cause for the
accident that tends to blame it on the
crew to make people believe that their
planes fine we just had a bad egg flying
it at the time when I've seen many
examples of that they do work with the
FAA and make recommendations with the
FAA quietly after all the claims are
settled and after it's out of the public
eye to try and fix some of the problems
but at the stage of the investigation at
the stage of the accident report it
usually isn't driven directly in the
direction of trying to make the plane
safer or aviation saver now I would add
that I think aviation has got much safer
in the last 30 years that I've doing the
business especially in their carrier
business I don't think in general
aviation it's got much safer but in the
air carrier business there's a lot of
things that have gone in the right
direction one crew training is much
better than it ever was the one single
thing there that makes it much better is
the the simulators are so much better I
mean I go to school today these days
twice a year for a week I mean flying a
simulator for one of the two jets that I
generally fly the training I used to
have back you know 15 20 years ago
compared to what I have today was lame
the training is very good today and it
trains to the least common denominator
the one thing that is advanced a lot in
aviation our avionics electronics of
flight management systems and navigation
systems like GPS
satellite-based navigation systems those
things have provided such much better
situation awareness to cruise they know
where they are better than they ever did
when I started flying freight as a young
man out of Detroit for the automotive
industry we don't know where we were
most of the time you know we're kind of
pointing in one direction hoping we
would find something on the ground that
would tell us where we were or some
radio signal I remember flying into
Detroit oftentimes looking for w jr
which was seven hundred and sixty Hertz
you know radio station for music and
morning talk show and I was so glad to
get my needle pointing of that direction
knowing it I mean today we we know we're
within feet I mean within a few feet all
the time we've got displays computer
displays in front of us that show the
airplane and show what its relative
position is and what its situation is in
all degrees of freedom so the view from
the cockpit is so good now that you I
often tell people you really only need
one pilot and the dog you need the pilot
to feed the dog the dog to pipe the bite
the pilot if he touches anything because
everything works pretty well by itself
but on the other hand that switch to
automation where you really hire you
have to monitor that very carefully and
oftentimes the automation does something
that you don't think it should do or
something that it shouldn't do and
what's the answer to that usually reboot
well if you're you know you're three
miles from touchdown the weather is bad
you've got ice in your wings you might
have to shoot a missed approach and all
of a sudden something goes you know
upside down on you you better know what
it is that happened and you better know
how to revert back to basic data and
basic airmanship and that's the thing
that is getting away from the younger
newer cruise because they start with
automation and that's what they know
they text you know two weeks before they
went to flight training they were
champion at texting on their cell phone
they know how to button push they don't
really understand
and the systems from the standpoint of
Herman ship and haha hydraulics and
pneumatics and the electrical systems
they know how to push buttons and how to
react to button pushing and messages and
so there's something lost but all in all
I think the system has been made safer
by the kind of technology that's in the
cockpit aerodynamically the airplanes
have been flat for years I still say to
juries that the spirit of Wichitas still
the spirit of st. Louis it's a high high
wing single-engine monoplane but it
costs more and go slower
yes you can go back to a crash of
american airlines in cali colombia where
we've reconstructed that in the cockpit
regularly and we see the pilots are
confused and they're saying what's it
doing now why is it doing that why is
the autopilot doing this why is it
turning as in that direction I thought
we were supposed to be going in this
direction instant in the simulators
where I spend probably 12 days a year
even even these days flying different
airplanes the comment that I hear more
often than any either from the
instructor or from one of the crews I'm
flying with or for myself is why is it
doing that it's not supposed to be doing
that so I mean that is a common problem
airplanes have been flown into the
ground they've been flown into mountains
in cali colombia that was the case was
flown right into a mountain because the
automation the flight management system
basically flew it right into a mountain
so we have seen that the other thing
we're seeing is there's a lot of use of
composite materials as compared to
metals metals we had a pretty good
understanding of what their strengths
were their ultimate strength their
fatigue strength their compressive
strength or tensile tensile strength
what have you composite materials are
just coming to age in terms of
homogeneity and in terms of being
consistent and having exactly the same
properties all the time because they're
evolving so fast we had an American
Airlines crash out of JFK here a bound
for the Dominican Republic probably four
years ago that was a case where the
vertical tail came off that was attached
using composite structure or commbuys
that materials rather than metal
materials and the tail broke off great
example of what I was referring to
before though the NTSB investigation
really didn't want to ground the Airbus
so the investigations substantially
pointed at the crew claiming that they
put in rudder inputs that caused the
tail to break
well at the speed that they were at
which was well below maneuvering speed a
pilot in airmanship that had learned to
be a pilot from days gone by would use
any kind of control inputs they could
use to try and recover the airplane when
it got in the vortex behind the airplane
out of it which is that the case I
believe they were flying behind a a jl
Japan Airlines 747 which sheds a pretty
good vortex and they got caught in the
vortex and the recovery technique they
used rudders and so the NTSB had an
escape there where they could point to
the pilots overuse of the rudder to
recover the airplane and that's why the
tail broke off I don't believe that for
a minute I believe that the reality was
that then I'm composite materials that
attach the tail to the fuselage was a
flawed material so but you'll see little
bits of information along those lines in
the NTSB report but they work pretty
hard at putting it on the crew
well one thing we don't have much left
in the way competition in the aircraft
industry you know when I graduate
graduated from aeronautical engineering
school in the big airplane air transport
area we had Boeing convair Lockheed
General Dynamics Douglas McDonald etc
today they're basically is one company
in the United States the Boeing Airplane
Company in general aviation we had many
more competitors so there isn't a lot of
competition in the business certainly
within the United States even on a
global basis what we have on a global
basis is Airbus and Boeing and that's it
and we're very also very very limited
also in general aviation in that respect
there's not a lot of competition the
advancements have now been as they have
in many areas of life been in the IT
area or in what what they call
technology today which basically means
electronics the airframes that that's
the airplane itself and the power plants
I've been fairly flat in progression the
I I expected that today we would be
flying higher much faster I thought we'd
be finding more in the outer edges of
the atmosphere and we would be
aerodynamically much cleaner than we are
part of the problem is to get an
airplane to certification is such a long
terribly expensive capital intensive
project to date that it's almost
impossible so many people have tried for
an example to make the very light jets
in the last 10 years and gone totally
broke they probably have talked to him
or seeing some of them but I no no no
one that has successfully produced a new
light jet aircraft
I I don't think so i think that that
that the intellectual property I believe
the ideas to make airplanes much better
and to make travel in the atmosphere and
even outside the atmosphere for that
matter is there and that's one of the
reasons that provoked me to think about
this beyond the edge project that we're
on right now and one of the reasons that
I'm here is we've got to find that
technology and we have to share it and
bring it to fruition there are many
young people young expansive as I would
call them with ideas that we you know
are not able to get together for one
reason or the other the same kind of
problems I had when I was young men in
the aircraft industry and also I think
that we have some very mature people
some great ideas who really aren't
sharing their ideas today because of
either ego or a fear of losing control
or financial issues and what we have to
do is create a safe place to bring that
kind of know how those ideas those new
thinkers together in a collaborative
sort of way so that we can bring them to
bring it to fruition I think there's
just a lot of great stuff out there this
kind of stuck with no place to go either
they don't know how to capitalize it or
they don't are they're afraid to share
it because of fear of losing their idea
not having control ego problems we have
to get ourselves into a more broad i
would say concentric way we have to you
know move well beyond ego concentric to
what andrew cohen refers to as a cosmos
concentric and at least a global
concentric so that we really share
outside of the constraints of you know
ego and financial fears the ideas that
we have to make them work so and and I
think that's evolving in that direction
my son used to always say a five you're
not living on the edge you're taking up
too much space and I was thinking well
maybe all the great ideas are somewhere
in the middle how do we move them out to
the edge and beyond the edge and into
fruition and I got to thinking in terms
of travel on the planet whether it was
on the surface of the water or whether
it was on land locomotion whether it was
in the atmosphere or maybe should be
outside the atmosphere and how you do
that in a clean fashion because I looked
at this way we're we're 10 years past
y2k 24-7 we move people up down sideways
across the surface of the planet in in
the atmosphere and what have you and for
the most part we're doing with
hydrocarbon fuels which are having a
very detrimental effect on our ecosystem
and our planet and the survival of the
planet sometimes it just will be a
matter of taking a great idea that a
young person has and helping them find
the information that's necessary to
bring it to fruition and the capital and
without the fear that they're going to
have to give something a way to do it
I've had many experiences just in the
last month of being able to talk to
young engineers or young expansive zaz
we would call them with with great ideas
and be able to help them along the path
to making it real
well I'm sure it's not an original
thought by any stretch but I think that
suborbital travel is is a concept that
makes a lot of sense for a scientist to
look at right now you know the globe
turns a thousand nautical miles every
hour so let's take some advantage of
that if you wanted to travel from New
York to Sydney why not get out to the
outer edges of the atmosphere either
re-enter skip off of the atmosphere and
re-enter into Sydney or what have you
you could do it at tremendous speeds you
could do it with a lot less energy I
believe although there's a lot of debate
on that right now how you do it you know
is it would be a great concept great
prize for competition but that excites
me that idea the idea of blasting
through the atmosphere at altitudes of
30 to 45 thousand feet and all the time
seems to me to be very energy
inefficient and also right now we're
using a lot of carbon fuels and we're
doing a lot of damage to the atmosphere
into the planet
well you know Eagle is a big issue
because people like to be connected with
what they created money obviously making
money and having power is a very
important thing tied to ego and
certainly gets in the way of sharing and
people being willing to you know release
their ideas I think that you for me it's
very possible to create a safe place for
young people with good ideas it's a
matter of trust as a matter of people
trusting each other and having you know
having no fear that they're going to be
taken advantage of or be hurt from
either an ego standpoint or a financial
standpoint the method of doing that I
think you have to do it by raising the
level of consciousness of the of people
particularly in scientific world to a
point where they really believe that in
order we have to improve our culture we
have to get unstuck from where we are I
don't have much trouble to communicating
with scientists on that level to me is
very similar to communicating with
juries personally I don't have a lot of
trouble with it I've I think I've been
able to make a few young engineers feel
very safe to disclose their information
to me and trust me with it what I'm
trying to develop is a system of what
you call mature scientists in expansive
thinkers that can do that with that can
make a safe place for people to share
ideas and that's the work in progress
that's where we're evolving
every day I meet more new ones I think
that on in the last month or so I've met
some that I some whose names I could
give freely like Peter Diamandis I think
it is great along these lines it was he
was a great fine for me I think that
some people in terms of helping to
expand the level of consciousness people
like Andrew Cohen from enlightenment
next I think that kind of teaching will
help tremendously to expand people so
that they will you know work for the
good of their culture is compared to the
egocentric kind of inventors that we
have really had historically so every
day I meeting more people that I think
that will make this inner circle work
and and I've met several people whose
names I wouldn't feel real freely to
give right now because I don't think
they would feel safe but I think they
will very shortly
what's interesting you know I'm driving
a hundred percent electric car for
example the Tesla which is a great
concept because I think that Tesla has
done what needed to be done to let
people know that to have an electric car
didn't mean you had to be a driving a
breadbox looking ugly green sort of
thing that we might find in Boulder
Colorado but you could actually look
kind of sporty and and go fast and it's
a it's a great performer in a great
little car and it's a hundred percent
electric I think that we still have to
look at you know what it costs to make
the electricity and how much carbon fuel
hydrocarbon fuels were used to make the
electricity to make the to store in the
car to make the car go it's a great
performer it it's very highly
competitive to apportion in terms of
performance I think that is great not
that it's new and innovative but
electric boats are very easy that's why
there aren't more electric boats it is
difficult hard for me to imagine but I
it was Christmas time I rented a hundred
percent electric boat and spent
Christmas Day on electric bout it works
fine and it has a lot of advantages over
carbon fuels and motors and internal
combustion engines and diesel engines
and what have you so I think that's
another area where we can do real well
in the ocean is a big part of my own
passion I do a lot of sailing which is
another again not innovative but there
are some real new innovative ways to
make saline more efficient and even more
available for commercial use I think
some some of the things in sport
aviation or sport sailing could be some
of that some of those ideas and some of
that technology could be really
transferred to commercial shipping in it
kind of a I love it because it's a
combination of aerodynamics and
hydrodynamics so that's great so those
are those are some things other than
aviation those are on the surface and
then you know the idea of
of traveling beyond the atmospheres in a
rocketry and space mechanics are also
very interesting because I think they
can solve a lot of problems
well one of the problems is that you
know we have regulation systems that
make it very difficult to take risk to
try new things for example if you try to
design a new airplane today many of
things that inhibit airplane design are
the federal air regulations now on one
hand that's real important from the
standpoint of safety but it makes it
very difficult for innovation because
we're stuck in these old regulations
that were the design criteria that we're
back you know basically created back in
the mid 50's or even before that for air
transports so the that that part of the
infrastructure if you will call it
infrastructure is inhibiting rather than
helpful understanding that it's
necessary for safety there just has to
be another way to be able to advance
this technology and to take the risk for
new ideas without having the
infrastructure prevent that from
happening of things so many aviation I
just just haven't come to fruition
because of the infrastructure and
another problem is that the regulated
have become the regulator's to a large
extent you know in the aviation industry
we could say that they know the Boeing
Airplane Company you know certifies
their own airplanes and or tells the FAA
when they're going to certify them and
how they're going to certify them so the
system is kind of turned around on
itself a little bit
I think listening to people that have
expertise in the in the areas or in the
fields of Transportation rather than I
and I'm talking about people as compared
to corporations that it can do that are
in control of the economy and I want to
make that distinction I think there's a
tremendous number of people that never
get listened to and if you go to
Congress and you go to a subcommittee
into a hearing and what have you all of
the people who testify for the most part
are the heads of Industry the heads of
the airlines the heads of the airplane
manufacturer we need to get some of the
people out of the universities we need
to get some of the ideas you know out of
the hangars out of the Experimental
Aircraft Association some of the
grassroots people who have some great
innovative ideas and get the people who
are in control of government to listen
to them it one of these I loved about
the courtroom is to a large extent we
had the experts we used were people from
the University they were people that
were learning and teaching as compared
to people who were in control of
industry
well I think one thing that would would
work would be to have some system in
place where Congress listens to the
teachers and though in the students from
the academic institutions some of the
cutting edge edge academic institutions
I know at the university colorado where
I've worked substantially there's some
great things going on in the minds of
young people and there's some great
things going on in the laboratories but
that's where they are I know I want
those things to be on the floor of
Congress to be competing with the
industry input I mean I grew up in
Detroit where when when I was in high
school the phrase was what was good for
General Motors was good for the world
well we all know better you know we knew
how to make vehicles when I went the
University of Detroit and mechanical
engineering we know how to make vehicles
with very high qualitative fuel usage
per mile or per gallon as compared to
what they did I mean the idea of driving
internal combustion engines at with 12
miles per gallon fuel usage was you know
it's ridiculous but they perpetuated
that for 40 years and we have to have
that challenge they knew how in the
universities and the labs and then the
best the best scientific thinkers years
ago knew how to fix that problem
first question I would ask is how you
fly through the atmosphere with a fuel
that's alternative to carbon fuel that
would be one of the first questions that
ask you know what's out there what can
we find and how can we find it an
alternative to a carbon fuel for flying
through the atmosphere or to reduce the
use of carbon fuel by say fifty percent
or seventy-five percent and that would
be a result of clean aerodynamics so
what how do we make aerodynamics clean
enough so that we use half the field we
use now I think that bird knows the
answer to that and I don't know birthday
well I know of him I think he knows the
answer to that but I think that he would
say that isn't being done because I
can't get it by the regulations or we
can't get it the capital or we can't get
it through industry we can't get it to
fruition you know in the foreseeable
future